et a désormais passer librement à
l'ouest et sans visa 19h09 tout à
l'heure à la télévision cette
information parfaitement inconcevable
voici enfants encore quinze jours
étaient directement donner aux
téléspectateurs une nouvelle dont nous
allons tenter d'imaginer toutes les
conséquences quelles sont en tout
premier lieu les réactions ce soir en
allemagne de l'est dont deux cent mille
citoyens ont fui le régime au cours des
derniers mois voici cette réaction que
nous venons de recevoir de notre envoyé
spécial
hélène risacher à berlin est oui oui on
connaît la nouvelle on a entendu à la
radio dans une ville et vous êtes
heureux et commencer le bonheur n'est
pas différent est ce que vous viendrez
tous les jours différents que nous dit
oui on viendra tous les jours et nous
avons des amis depuis 1957 ici que nous
sommes retraités
nous avions le droit de venir mais on
reviendra encore plus souvent est dure
mais mon ami oui mon mari un frère
et puis des amis c'est pour ça qu'on est
là le plus souvent possible
à partir de demain matin lorsque leur
papier seront en règle tous les
allemands de l'est pourront se rendre
dans le monde entier sans visa de sortie
de rda sans surveillance particulière
réciproquement les allemands de l'ouest
pourront se rendre à l'est sans visa
particulier contrairement à ce qui se
passait jusqu'à présent ceux souvent les
postes frontières était à l'image des
deux côtés de berlin très calme même
s'ils sont tous très heureux pour
l'instant les berlinois ne manifeste pas
dans les rues mais pour eux maintenant
le mur n'est plus un mur alors de
l'autre côté de la frontière en
allemagne de l'ouest la population elle
aussi est sous le choc
elle avait suivi avec beaucoup de
sympathie l'arrivée des réfugiés
aujourd'hui le sentiment en allemagne de
l'ouest est beaucoup plus ambigu
reportage que nous venons de recevoir de
fr3 strasbourg des moments comme ça je
vous nommer
au canada le 5 août
si tu dois être franc j'ai connu à
toulouse
voilà donc des commentaires nous faisons
le journal en direct avec vous puisque
ce reportage nous arriver directement
alary pardon nous n'avions pas encore eu
le temps de le sous titre est un
problème technique de piste nous le
faisons vraiment sans filet